[Music]
hi i'm tyler hey tyler what's on your
mind uh a lot of things but i'll i'll
centralize it to one question
um
so this isn't about
grief or trauma that's already happened
it's about
something that may happen so my wife and
i we have three parents that are in
their mid-70s
how do we
prepare for that because they all have
health issues
so
we want to be proactive rather than
reactive
shall i yes yes please
i'm a big fan of open communication and
i don't know how your parents are i know
that sometimes there's this generational
thing where people are really
uncomfortable talking about end of life
stuff but i find that talking about it
it's like the elephant in the room right
i mean
we all have to face it at some point and
we think that talking about it actually
makes our lives dark or
unpleasant but actually in sociological
research what we found was that people
who are willing to confront difficult
issues like this actually find more
meaning in their lives and they have
more perspective and they love people
and use things like
love people and use things less right
and so uh this this idea of uh
confronting hard subjects and having
really vulnerable and open conversations
about end of life is really important so
i
would invite you to very gently and
tenderly ask them you know how do you
feel about a conversation about this
and then start preparing yourself for
the inevitable which is grief i mean i
think that the way that i look at grief
it's not just the single monolithic
emotional structure it's uh it's an it's
like an umbrella that and underneath the
umbrella there are so many emotions with
grief uh there's sadness and sorrow and
despair and anguish and sometimes anger
and rage confusion envy
i mean there are so many but also
curiosity and connection and openness
and so
i i think i would sort of try to learn
as much as you can
while inviting them to a conversation
is that helpful
thank you thank you tyler yeah that's
great advice yeah you can clap for that
you know i um a few years ago i i got
really really sick and i said to start
talking to my wife about hey what if
what if i'm not here and i found it to
be an incredibly
freeing communication
and it's
upsetting and there was some grieving
that went on there like just
as you see there you sort of grieving
the hypothetical in a way
and you see you're preparing for
something that might happen well it's
certainly going to happen to all of us
right and yet i found in our culture
specifically we are scared to death to
talk about death
yeah we're even more scared to talk
about grief oh
why is that
uh hard emotions i mean it just brings
up tears i mean there are death cafes
they're called death cafes and those are
popping up all over the place where
people are talking about end of life
issues for themselves and preparing
doing their advance directives uh but
you know grief i listen i don't get
invited to parties very often just so
you know
this is like as close to a party as i've
been in 20 years y'all hi
[Applause]
you know i i tell you a funny story i
teach i teach a traumatic death class at
asu and i walked into the class once and
i'm unpacking my things it was the first
day of class and i heard these students
in the front going is that her and the
other one's going i don't know she seems
awfully happy
they expected like the grim reaper to
come in you know well i think that's
what's fascinating about that is we we
confuse someone who is truly joyous
joy makes room for other emotions such
as grief or sadness
they can hold things simultaneously it's
different from pleasure in that way you
can't be experiencing ecstatic pleasure
and also grief at the same time so what
do we do we try to avoid grief by
constantly consuming things that bring
us momentary ecstatic pleasure right and
then see here's the problem this is my
theory about that my theory is that we
don't know how to feel all of our
emotions and fully inhabit our emotions
and so
we
fill our lives with things instead of
really connecting with our true self but
if we can learn how to reclaim all of
our emotions which are some of the hard
emotions then we don't need that [ __ ]
right because we are who we are right
yeah
yeah
[Music]
yeah
yeah it's
it's interesting because it is possible
to like i have been sad before but able
to still experience joy and the way that
i got there and it i mean it was the
first time ever happened uh it was
earlier this year actually i was on a
camping trip
and i was talking to someone about um
my mom and dad issues and like just kind
of laying it all out there with a friend
and i started to like tear up and get
really sad about you know the
relationship i wish i had
and i just had this like feeling
just rushed over me where i was like
you know what man like hey like i really
like who i am as a person so that's huge
like if you can really look in the
mirror and love who you see but the
other thing is i felt really lucky
to like even have the experience to feel
sadness to have that opportunity to feel
the emotion like that is that's a that's
a gift
i mean i forget what the odds are of
like a human being being born but it's
like astronomical like we're lucky we're
lucky to be able to have these emotions
and yeah talking about them more i think
is helps us yeah step through them a
little bit more i'll tell you the one
thing about your parents
if you
no matter if these are your parents
romantic partner friend co-worker if you
start these tough conversations
and you lead with compassion and that's
your context for the conversation those
conversations will always go as well as
they can go i mean they're still not
easy conversations to have but sometimes
we get these negative emotions and then
we start to project kind of the negative
feelings and that's where it can really
kind of go wrong but i would just
encourage you
approach it with compassion and like i'm
sure your parents will be open to
all
it
thank you did you enjoy this standalone
patreon highlight if so you can listen
to full episodes of the minimalist
private podcast available exclusively on
patreon visit
patreon.com slash the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and youtube
channel 100
advertisement free